داعش يمول عمليته الارهابيه
بالرومانسيه العالم اصبح 8 مليارات نسمه
والهند قد تتجاوز الصين ماسك يطرد موظفا
خطاه امام الجميع على تويتر هذه الاخبار
وغيرها منقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
بعد انحسار نشاطه اثر ضربات المتتاليه
التي وجهت اليه لجاء تنظيم داعش الارهابي
الى حيله جديده لتمويل عملياته عبر تطبيق
تندر الشهير للمواعده وبحسب ما ورد في
تقرير نشرته صحيفه تايمز بريطانيه فان
داعش اعتمد طرقا رومانسيه تقوم على
محادثات وصور وهميه خاصه بالاصدار الجنوب
افريقي لخداع بعض المستخدمين وابتزازهم
للحصول على اموال لكي يستخدمها في تمويل
اعماله في القارات السمراء وحضرتها هيئه
الرقابه على الحيله التي تتطور عاده بمجرد
ان يقوم المحتالون بنقل المواعده عن
المواقع الرسميه
والى خبر اخر حيث وصل اليوم عدد سكان
الارض الى ثمانيه مليارات نسمه وفقا
لتقارير اميه ترصد زياده السكانيه البشريه
على الكوكب وارجعت السبب الى ان الناس
باتوا يعمرون اكثر بفضل تحسن خدمات الصحه
العامه والتغذيه والنظافه الشخصيه
والادويه ومع تفاوت معدلات النمو السكانيه
حول العالم حافظت الهند على نمو قوي حيث
من المتوقع ان تتجاوز الصين لتصبح الدوله
الاكثر اكتظاظا على وجه الارض بحلول منتصف
العام المقبل
وفي فصل جديد لطريقه ادارتها الغريبه قام
الملياردير الامريكي الين ماسك بطرد موظف
في تويتر عبر تغريده مباشره على المنصه
قصه طرد بدات حين غرد ماسك معتذرا لبطء
تويتر في العديد من البلدان لاسيما على
نظام اندرويد ليرد الموظف وهو مطور برمجه
في الشركه مؤكدا ان تلك الادعاءات خاطئه
وفي غير محلها وسرعان ما تطورت الامور مع
تدفق ردود الافعال وانتقاد البعض للموظف
معتبرين انه كان من الاحرى به ان يناقش
هذا الامر مع مديرها على انفراد قبل ان
يقرر ماسك طرده
والهولندا حيث اعلنت وزاره العدل والصحه
الهولنديتان في بيان المشترك حضره حيازه
او بيع اكسيد النيتروجين المعروف بغاز
الضحك والذي يستخدمه شباب كفر خلال
الاحتفالات او المناسبات الاجتماعيه رغم
مخاطره واكد البيان ان حضره اكسيد
النيتروجين سيدخل حيز التنفيذ في الاول من
يناير من عام 2030
لادراجه في القائمه الثانيه للقانون بشان
الافيون وسيبقى لاستخدام المهني لاكسيد
النيتروجين مسموحا في الاوساط الطبيه او
الغذائيه
وفي خبرنا الاخير حقق طفل يدعى يوسف شاه
يبلغ احد عشر عاما اعلى درجه ممكنه في
اختبار الوكاله العالميه للذكاء متفوقا
بذلك على العالم الفيزيائي البرت اينشتاين
والفيزيائيه الشهير ستيفن هوكينج وسجل
الطفل البريطاني درجه ذكاء بلغت
162 وهي الحد الاقصى لمن هم دون الثامنه
عشر كما انها النسبه الاعلى بين الاشخاص
جميعهم يشار الى ان معظم الاشخاص يحصلون
على درجات تتراوح بين 85 درجه
و155 نقطه وهو يعتبر متوسط معدل الذكاء
ووفقا لصحيفه ديل ميل البريطانيه فان عالم
الفيزياء هوكينج سجل 100 درجه كما يعتقد
ان اينشتاين قد حقق النتيجه ذاتها
[موسيقى]